hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
moans ooh it is gum Morgan hey
that's not your dog no it's not my dog
it's my neighbor's dog you like it they
also have like ten kids next door in a
two-bedroom apartment speaking of dogs
animals are good timing
good timing dog yeah yeah there's the
one video I might be acceptable and your
background noise on boring history here
I've had this video bookmarked to watch
for the longest time deal yeah because
it I go by request and this video is
requested I've never seen it but a lot
man that dogs gamma freakin nerves let's
go next door answer your dog for a
second thank you your dog I feel like
I'm sure your dog
I like watching Hannibal to dumb things
right it's about watching let's see I've
done these animals are stupid animals
[Laughter]
what is that looks like I've heard your
money join em how do you bro you fear
the snap
happy holidays my boy you stayed out the
hair now you just like your pops we best
friends now bro yeah
yo my boy is about to be Christmas so I
got you some nice kicks burn these some
new John's right here when you doing
yeah check them out check do you think
they fit you you think they fit you yeah
[Music]
what is that
that's our the dog is [ __ ] nice oh
my god we gotta do that too I can't
watch this one watch it Morrigan no
she's too into it
[Music]
Oh what is that a monkey chimp yeah that
was probably poop I can't oh I can't was
that Wow Oh missed how creepy oh my god
the real dog's head no what do you
really kill the dog and put that Mouse
know that another dog pooping you
literally slip the hidden camera got it
[Laughter]
stupid
[Music]
[Laughter]
is he yes to keep him warm I don't think
so I think you just decided to pee hey
you feeling now take the bag off his
head so mean that the animal abuse is it
yes
oh my god that's a no no no idea
I wish media like explosive shots off of
the poop coming out just on that yeah
like as tight as possible humans are
being idiots she was not adorable
that was super enjoy you don't have a
pet do you no not in my apartment but I
grew up with dogs oh did you
I grew up with cats obviously I'm a cat
guy we had dogs and cats we and all of
them we always had $2 and two cats
is it mean to put a bag of chips the
empty one over a cat's head because I've
always thought that'd be funny they do
to my cat I think it's funny until they
start to hurt themselves and clearly
want out it's hard the funny comes if
that's animal abuse is it I'm pretty
sure they would arrest you now they're
super serious but they never knew well
then just do you have a bag of Fritos on
you submit videos it was me behind it
follow the clues ODI BTK
with the balloon with the dog we got
tread doesn't Ashley Ashley has those
all candy we gotta tie that little area
[Music]
yeah was that was a fart reference never
do when we intend for it Aaron see we
got to do this to a dog not be so
freakin adorable to do to a public that
video we're making for the dog showing
their teeth and sorry that amazes me
it's ending with cats whenever my cats
are in another room with a new cat yeah
like they're so sweet that scares me
with dogs and they do that because
dachshunds look so sweet but once they
get like invited the defense mode their
face chance like they become a totally
different animal at that time man I've
seen it how do you see me oh yeah oh my
god it's the hottest thing in the world
I've never seen you man
why can't you watch that one with the
mouse going in the person he is first of
all it's a rat but I thought you were
into like Oh TMI but I thought you were
into you know rat porn yeah that's what
I would know when you have you know you
and your boyfriend you're not allowed to
talk to me like this he'll be very upset
and then the mouse I have no idea what
you're referencing if you're referencing
something sexual I don't have
you know works your gear you know I
don't talk to you like this off-camera
when they put a mouse up the other hole
yeah that's a thing there are people
that do that what's that called Mouse I
thought it was called the Morgan can we
say your boyfriend's name Morgan and
Bobby oh but the one with it is he
pooping he captures the poop in his hand
then Chuck's it and it got grandma right
on the face oh my god that is so gross
oh but that one that creeped me out was
the moment to go dogmas I keep wondering
if you kill the real daughter works head
yeah you're insulting every place
outside of America oh wow are they guy
I've never still fun dog poop I've
stepped on dog then there slipped I
don't think that's always the worst
especially you don't know for a while
that panic in your heart like oh my god
did I stepped in poop and it's like
you've been walking for a while so it's
like really pushing Oh God that's the
worst I never know how to get it out I
once watched it then dry clean my shoe
it [ __ ] that much actually it's not
like there's a head rolling around
that's good that's good advice right
there you don't like when dogs lick your
mouth
like anything like even unless it's your
man the love of your life the love of
mine only he should like Morgan's no I'm
making that quitter if you meet Morgan
in person do not lick her mouth
I don't like dog licks either dogs are
Catlett's anywhere that really don't
like it's like you get a dog is like an
over liquor and they lick your hands in
your own love that hiding me gently and
then like continue with your day that's
what she was stuck I'm seeing curious
hidden licking my mouth really yeah you
know what it's me humans and dogs do not
like Morgan's mouth unless you were
Bobby and the nastiest dog there is
Bobby Edna what it's appropriate hey no
I won't Bobby - come on this channel I
know he should he's super fun I'm gonna
come on this channel and take his shirt
off no no one else is actually yeah
because you know what I like that
everybody I like that he's obviously hot
yeah people hit on him yeah I know he's
really good-looking guys I like that
he's obviously hot because then it's
like yeah you better come I get to come
home when my girlfriend gets hit on in
public I like it too then I like getting
racially jealous in the way you dress
that's why yeah that's what it gets
really then she calls the cops I'm
talking to them oh man does that turn me
on
well you shouldn't joke like that
apparently click that notification bell
follow Morgan hand on social media how
to blondes make a right on Instagram and
how to's and Morgan Ashley on YouTube
good day America we love you